[Music]
let's go out to the home of the greatest
food on planet Earth San Antonio Texas
and talk to Sarah what's up
Sarah hi Dr joh how are you I'm hanging
in there how are you about the same oh
boy so what's
up um so I I need some help I'm I'm very
exhausted and overwhelmed handing
handling a situation with my husband and
my 15-year-old son uh oh it's two
separate
situations um let's start with husband
husband okay um my husband hasn't worked
now in 10 and a half
months and I he got fired um from his
job and I I don't know he makes excuses
of why he can't go to work
why he doesn't try to to find a job it's
he gets too distracted there's too many
things to do um this then it's just one
excuse after
another I don't know you how has that
gone in your home I mean who's paying
bills are you out working
too yes but right now I'm on maternity
um I've been out since the end of August
so you have a 15-year-old and an infant
well there's actually four kids 15 13
we're a blended family okay um those two
kids are from my previous marriage and
then we have two kids a two-year-old and
then a newborn good God so what does he
do all
day um sometimes he sleeps he sleeps for
hours he's got a lot of mental health
issues going on uhhuh sounds like he's
struggling yes and um he'll get
distracted busy himself was
straightening things emping containers
filling
containers um so let me ask let me ask
you this I have a hard hard question to
ask just to kind of cut to the chase
sure are you g to leave him are you
almost
done I actually yes I've been strongly
considering separation
okay when you've been facing this for a
year um 10 months right you're basically
been doing this for a year um you have
to have in mind your or what
conversation and what I mean by your or
what conversation is you sit down and
say you have to go see a doctor or a
psychologist or a counselor within the
next seven days or I'm moving
out you have to go get a job and begin
going to the job every
day and we've had by the way the Great
greatest run of job opportunities in
American history the last 36 months 24
months he can get a job tomorrow he can
get a job today he can get two jobs
today and actually depending on what his
what his mental health diagnostic is who
knows what he's going through if he's
got depression disorder if he's got who
knows
but often getting up and getting a job
is helpful it gives you a thing to go
towards it gives you a purpose a role it
gives you meaning right not every
situation that's why it needs to go see
somebody but you have to have a very
firm or
what because you've been him hauling and
hinting at this and getting mad at him
for 10 months now right right what didd
he get fired
for
stealing what was he
stealing money and gift
cards well that might make it hard to
get a job jeez
Louise
yeah what was his response to getting
caught and getting
fired um
he he was very I wouldn't say remorseful
I think he was more panicked that he got
caught and and
shocked is that the kind of guy he
is no well not the kind of guy that I
thought he was we've been married since
um no I really I was shocked when I
found out that he was stealing um that's
not the husband that I know that wasn't
in his character however later to find
out he was fired from two other jobs for
stealing and I did not know that oh well
gez hey Sarah lead with that next time
okay lead with that yeah so you're
married to somebody who is a crook who
steals and is constantly fired from his
job
repeatedly
fair this is not a fair question but I
have to ask it why did you go through
and have kid number
four um he so I found out I was pregnant
one week before he was fired oh jeez I'm
so sorry I'm happy that your baby's
coming I hope your baby's healthy and
wonderful and all that's great and
I can just imagine how much this
complicates
things yeah what is your
plan if you moved out tomorrow what
would your plan be where would you
go um
so what I would want I've been working
with a counselor I would want him to
move out okay we're in a three veterum
apartment we had a house we had to sell
the house when he lost his job and
wouldn't work and I would want him out
and the kids and I stay in the apartment
can you afford
that when I go back to work yes it'll be
tight but yes okay the research tells me
unfortunately that when somebody has to
leave their husband for any number of
reasons the husband's net worth goes up
a little bit and her net worth goes down
somewhat significantly especially in the
short
term yeah so I want to make sure you
have an iron clad
plan right and I don't right now that's
what I'm trying to work on and that's
why I haven't done
anything I need you to I need you to
stop trying to work on this and I need
you to get very tactical very quick okay
do you have somebody in your life you
could have that conversation
with yes a counselor okay also at the
end of this call I want you to hang on
I'm going to give you a couple of free
financial coaching
calls with the team at Ramsey Solutions
okay and they will help you build a
budget that is based on real numbers and
real
life okay okay thank
you but practicing with your counselor
is really smart and next time you go to
your counselor I want you to say these
words I'm ready to practice my final
conversation and they can help you write
it they can help you script it they can
help you speak it out loud feel it in
your body so that when you actually sit
down across from your husband and you
lay it out there um you have rehearsed
it okay okay
now well let me just say this I'm sorry
this isn't how it's supposed to
be the guy you married and have kids
with is not supposed to be secretly
stealing from his business and then you
find out he's been doing it for
years husbands are not supposed to get
fired and then sit around for 10 months
people get fired life happens people get
laid off that happens that's life but
you don't get to sit around for 10
months while your pregnant wife is
working up until the day she has a baby
I'm sorry that's not supposed to be how
that is he's supposed to be out there
with four jobs and he's going to be very
hard to hire right now because he's been
dishonest so many
times but he can get a job mowing lawns
and he can get a job delivering for Uber
and he can get a job delivering pizzas
and he can get a job at a dog grooming
place he could figure it out he's
choosing he can get a job with all the
building that's going on in San Antonio
he can get a job on a
site but he's choosing not to and he can
go deal with his mental health
challenges and he's choosing not
to yeah are you safe
Sarah um yes
Why the
pause sorry it's
okay he's been getting more
Angry um verbally abusive towards me and
the kids um yeah few weeks ago he left
my son stranded he kicked him out of the
car he was mad with his
attitude um how old is your son I'm
15 he's watching his dad constantly get
fired for
uh for being dishonest and then he's
watching his dad lay around the
house of course he's a 15-year-old with
an attitude he's watching his pregnant
mom float the whole family of course he
has an attitude
yeah do you have family in the area
Sarah
no my husband has family and they're all
um rather supportive and talking to me
of trying to figure out what to do what
what does that mean they're supportive
of him or they're supportive of you they
know he's a he's a dead
beat um they're supportive of me
okay what I like to look at in these
situations is trend lines escalation
lines and this seems to be trending in
the very wrong
direction it sounds like as you're
getting closer and closer to going back
to work and he is out longer and
longer he's getting angrier and angrier
and less safe and less safe true or
false I missed that true okay
so how much longer are you going to
wait that's the question that I can't
figure out you need to make a call
now I keep waiting and waiting it's not
going to happen you've waited a year and
now your kids are paying the price how
long are you going to
wait yeah because you're worth more than
this and you know that they're worth
more than this and you know that he's
worth more than this for God's
sake how much
longer
yeah do you think as a 30day time
frame to give him an ultimatum to have
full-time
employment within 30 days is appropriate
inappropriate too much too little what
what is your in
um I think he needs to be separated from
you guys immediately based on leaving a
15-year-old on the side of the
road because what that shows me is that
he is
emotionally either very very
immature or he is struggling profoundly
emotionally to the point that he can't
be in the presence of minor children
because he's letting his inability to
control himself as the adult in the room
or in the
car being managed by a child and that's
not your 15-year-old's job your
15-year-old's job is to push boundaries
and to figure out how the world works
it's Dad's job to act like Dad and to be
the firm responsible adult in that
interaction and he is unable to do that
right
now I don't mind 30-day separations or
ultimatums I think those are can be very
wise sometimes but they have to have
ground rules to them here's the
date we will reconvene in 30 days at
this restaurant at this time and by that
time you will show me you have three to
four weeks of weekly counseling you will
show me that you have full-time
employment at at least two places and
you will show me your first pay
stub and in the meantime I'm going to
meet with an attorney to begin drawing
up separation
papers
okay that means he's got to find a place
to live that means he's got to get real
responsible real
fast based on what you're telling me I
don't think he can make it but I do
understand your heart and not wanting to
be a single mom with four kids over like
suddenly
right yeah I get
that real quick what's your challenge
with your
15-year-old my my 15-year-old um he's
been
vaping yeah you know why cuz it
works that's what he says yeah I don't
blame that 15-year-old one second it's
dumb and it's GNA make him sick but good
God I don't blame that kid for a second
I'm glad that's all he's
doing it's probably not all he's doing
by the way but I'm
glad yeah he's been in therapy for a few
years years um he and he has a plan with
his counselor he he wants to quit by the
beginning of the new year what he says
wants to quit vaping yeah okay give him
give him an environment where his body
will let him
rest yeah needs peace he needs
peace anytime a 15-year-old heads into
any sort of substance use
a it it's uh it's a it feels good right
it's just different it's sensation and
kids seek sensation I got no problem
with with I I understand it right it's
the adult's job to make sure they don't
get their hands on that stuff and it's
the adult's job to talk it through and
it's the adult's job to play defense I'm
not ever going to get mad at a
14-year-old for wanting to feel like a
buzz to what it feels like to smoke a
cigarette or to feel like a dip or to
feel like whatever
but in this
situation I get it completely because
he's got to figure out some
way to bring his body down because his
body's at War
right yeah
yeah and by the way when you kick Dad
out you're going to be the bad guy for a
season you got to make peace with
that with your 15-year-old you're
playing a long game with
him cuz he sees himself in his father
right said
Dad it he's your kid that's
stepdad right where's his where's his
biod dad here in the same town but
they're a strange okay he sees himself
in his
dad and he knows part of me is that
guy that haunts him and the next example
of a man he has is his
stepdad who is so out of control he
dropped a 15-year-old off on the side of
the
road and the other half of him is his
mom who he's watching hold the whole
house
up but that boy need you're right that
boy needs peace you need peace Sarah
your whole household does here's what I
want you to do I want you to call your
counselor and say I'm ready to make a
30-day plan
I want you to Google Terry re I just
mentioned this in a in a recent episode
terry.com or Terren real.com t r r y and
I want you to Google the 10 rules of a
separation of a trial separation it will
pop up and he's got the 10 rules I want
you to print that off and take that with
your counselor and I want you to map it
out but I never am in the business of of
making this call you've decided you want
to do this I am in the business of
protecting kids
especially I think the time is now and I
want youall to get this thing practice
get this thing done and have that
conversation with husband
ASAP he needs help you need help and you
need some clarity and hang on the line
I'm going to hook you up with those
financial coaches I know that it's super
easy to be like you need to go it's time
there's a fiscal reality especially for
what's about to be single moms it's it's
harder than just you need to move on out
and Empower yourself okay cool but I
can't send empowerment certificates to
the to the lighting company right so
we're g to help you make a plan a road
map financially right with the Ramsey
Financial coaches so hang on the line
also I'm going to send you the every
dollar app I'm gonna send you FPU for a
year okay that's GNA be my gift to you
to give you some sort of plan to follow
financially after this whole mess is
over because there's going to be a very
significant fiscal reality to a
three-bedroom apartment in San Antonio
and four kids and one
income that's going to be tough tough
tough tough and you're worth it and you
might have to end up moving you might
have to make some calls for some support
and help in the interim you are worth it
thank you for the call call any time and
if husband wants to call I'd love to
talk to him
too